all right before we get to voicemails I
want to tell you about something which
it's one of these things where like it
very clearly seems like a lie but if it
were true it's almost even worse there's
a very interesting Rolling Stone article
which says that Trump told his White
House team that he needed to protect
quote russiagate documents okay so
understand this is the assertion being
made and we'll talk about whether it's
true the former president who left the
White House with a trove of sensitive
material believes there are documents
that would expose a deep State plot
against him and told confidants he
needed to protect them from the next
Administration so really I mean this is
crazy
but think about what it is that is it is
being being asserted here in this
Rolling Stone article
in his final days at the White House
Trump told advisors he needs to preserve
certain russia-related documents to keep
his enemies from destroying them ah okay
the documents relate to the federal
investigation into Russia election
meddling and alleged collusion with
Trump's campaign
at the end of his president presidency
Trump and his team pushed to declassify
these so-called Russia gate documents
believing they would expose a deep State
plot against him according to a person
with direct knowledge of the situation
and another source briefed on the matter
Trump told several people working in and
outside the White House he was concerned
that Biden's Administration or the quote
deep state would shred bury or destroy
the evidence that Trump was wronged this
is a newly relevant claim based on the
FBI search so let's kind of talk through
this right
if it is true that Donald Trump believed
he had to steal documents because they
exposed the Deep State plot against him
which the Biden Administration would
shred and destroy that is Bonkers nuts
but there's a second layer to this stuff
just because Trump said that's what he
believed doesn't mean it's actually what
he believed and what I mean by that is
if these documents really exonerated
Trump
why would he want to take them and hide
them these would be things you would
want to publicize and you can't rule out
that this is something that's being
brought up now to try to justify Donald
Trump taking the documents that he took
so so there's like three or four
different layers to this thing but again
if this was really what Trump said and
what Trump believed he is essentially a
q Anon right it the Republican Party
essentially elected Q Anon to the
presidency when they elected Donald
Trump but because it's Trump we never
want to ignore the possibility that this
is only what some are claiming Trump
said and he didn't really say it third
possibility that this is something Trump
said but didn't mean there's also you
you have to assume everybody might be
lying the people now telling Rolling
Stone Trump said this might be lying
Trump might have said it but might have
been dishonestly saying it to create
plausible deniability over taking the
documents anything is true it's a stack
of Lies it's it's like those Russian
Matryoshka dolls where you open the doll
and there's a smaller and smaller doll
in it it's lies and deception and lies
and deception all baked together almost
like a beef wellington of sorts I think
maybe is the way I would describe it
really wacky wacky stuff